tether just lost 10 billion dollars and
i want to talk about it welcome to
coffeezilla i'm your internet detective
so tether is the world's largest
stablecoin and it's had so many
controversies i couldn't even fit them
all in this 35 minute documentary i did
but despite the critics saying for years
that tether isn't backed and that its
collapse is imminent tether has just
sort of managed to stick around like a
cockroach in a greasy crypto kitchen
nobody likes them we all try to ignore
them but getting rid of them is
impossible without hurting business so
if all of that was true 11 months ago
when i first talked about tether what's
different this time well tether is in
danger of collapsing because for the
first time they're seeing an
unprecedented run on their reserves 10
billion dollars were redeemed over the
course of 14 days just these last two
weeks which is over 10 percent of their
total supply and in the event that
tether is not fully backed this is the
way we find out people keep asking for
their money until there's no money left
you can see it from the chart actually
there's never been anything like this in
tether's history already we saw what
happens when a coin the size of luna and
ust fails and tether is four times their
size so a collapse could be catastrophic
but if all of that sounds very scary let
me tell you the other side of the story
reasons you shouldn't be worried because
according to tether they're fully backed
one-to-one by us dollars or equivalents
unlike luna which wasn't backed at all
meaning tether could keep losing
billions in theory and still have money
to redeem their tethers right until the
very last one which is very unlike luna
tether also claims to be world class in
transparency and regularly releases
reports from accountants that agree
tether is a hundred percent backed your
money is safe so you might be wondering
why are so many people including myself
afraid tether will collapse the answer
is quite simple actually because tether
and their executives are about as
reliable as amber heard if you want to
know where all their money is if you
haven't already watched my documentary
on them tether mints new lies about as
often as their magic dollars they lied
for years that they were backed one to
one by us dollars and the new york
attorney general accuses them of
covering up losses to quote protect
their bottom lines
like holy crap so that's the thing i'm
not exactly accusing tether of beginning
to lie i'm saying if you want to believe
tether you have to believe they stopped
in the first place and that really is
the bullish case on tether nobody even
tries to defend their past actions other
than to say they've changed in fact
here's an example of that a reddit post
which says tether is shady but is it a
scam let's find out yeah believe it or
not that's a defense of tether and in
other news that house over there is
smoking but is it on fire not only that
defenders of tether also point to
attestations from independent
accountants how could this be a big
farce they say when tether releases
reports that are checked by accountants
right the only issue with this is that
those accountants are from the cayman
islands which you know it's sort of the
place you go to if you want to dodge
financial regulations and look i get it
some people think that accountants are
mystical creatures that are bound to the
truth and literally incapable of lying
but unfortunately they're just humans
there are good ones there are bad ones
and then they're outright fraudulent
ones like people seem to forget enron
you know which operated for 16 years on
the basis of fraudulent audits which
tether hasn't even released an audit
they've only done attestations meanwhile
enron got one of the top accounting
firms arthur anderson to say that they
were making billions of dollars in
profits while actually losing money like
that happened and if you had listened to
their independent accountants instead of
paying attention to all the red flags
you would have been fooled right up
until they collapsed and you lost all
your money so i do think something
similar could be happening here i think
people are underestimating the risk that
mha cayman which was formerly more
cayman is just lying outright and that's
not an accusation it's just a statement
of probabilities either tether has
stopped lying or they didn't and of the
two of them i personally think the
second is more likely but obviously it'd
be great to know for sure and one way we
might do that is by trying to get the
exact records of their reserves which
incidentally coindesk tried to do
and tether fought and has been fighting
in court they don't want to release the
information saying it would expose
proprietary business information
so there's that
tether doesn't seem to want everyone to
know the exact truth of how back tether
is really but whatever the number really
is whether it be 100 backed 99 back 50
20
really what that ends up meaning in
reality is that's just the number of
dollars they can redeem until they're
insolvent and that's exactly why it's
scary when suddenly people start
redeeming billions of dollars because
now we're stress testing this thing
that's sort of propping up a lot of the
crypto markets you only find out if a
bank doesn't have the money when people
decide to withdraw all at once and so
that's actually another thing i wanted
to talk about incidentally is who is
redeeming all this tether because it's
not the individuals making a run for it
your average joe it appears to be the
whales the guys in the know which is a
very scary thought we know this because
protos did a massive investigation into
who bought the majority of all tether
ever acquired and what they found is
that most of tether was bought by market
makers and big funds and companies
individuals only bought a tiny fraction
add to that the fact that you can't
redeem tether except in chunks of a
hundred thousand dollars or more and
this isn't retail traders that are
heading for the exits it's the whales
the institutions like alameda research
and funds who are taking their money out
and that begs the question what do these
big whales know are they just scared of
what happened with luna i don't know
it's possible
or is it something else either way i
would say if you see a lot of people
running towards an exit and you're not
you should probably wonder why they're
doing so and while i certainly hope
nobody loses any money on this thing
i think tether is ultimately a ticking
time bomb which incidentally is what
their logo sort of resembles a nuclear
bomb explosion anyways that's basically
all i wanted to talk about pump the
stock it's fully backed and thanks for
watching